hallo ihr lieben heute zeige ich euch
das rezept für den a kader ist eine
spezialität knapp heißt eigentlich
wortwörtlich übersetzt so was wie
fleischgericht und dieses fleischgericht
kommt immer aus adana
das ist ein spieß dem grillt mann der
muss auch gegrillt werden nicht auf gas
sondern auf holzkohle schmeckt es am
besten und ich zeige euch die
besonderheiten im rahmen unserer
möglichkeiten in deutschland zeige ich
euch quasi das original rezept ich sage
euch immer mal wieder was dazu weil wir
hier nicht alle möglichkeiten haben die
man in der türkei hat aber dazu geben
wir später noch ein
hier zeige ich euch erstmal unsere fünf
zutaten wir haben hier ein halb halb
verhältnis das heißt 500 gramm
rindfleisch von der rippe und hier haben
wir lange fleisch von der keule und hier
ist besonders viel fett dran und das
brauchen wir auch gleich sage ich euch
noch näheres zum fleisch außerdem
benötigen wir eine rote spitz paprika
salz und pool die welt dass die paprika
flocken da gibt es die süße variante und
die schafe ich habe hier halb halb
gemacht weil ich nicht so viel schafft
vertragen kann
im original rezept gibt es keine
bindemittel wie zb paniermehl mail oder
das wird ganz einfach durch das fed
gebunden was wir haben und ich habe
jetzt hier im land vielleicht besonders
viel fett das habe ich mir geben lassen
vom mit charakter einfach nach ihr könnt
auch von mir sagen ich habe vor adana zu
machen oder wissen die eigentlich schon
bescheid normalerweise kommt dann noch
wie gesagt eine dritte zutat rein und
das ist das ziel am schwanz fest das
bekommen wir hier in deutschland leider
nicht das bekommt in der türkei aber
hier eben nicht deswegen müssen wir
darauf verzichten und nehmen eben hier
ein bisschen mehr fett und die andere
besonderheit ist dass wir das nicht
durch einen fleischwolf geben das heißt
wir hatten das jetzt selber denn wenn
wir das schon als hackfleisch kaufen
dann verliert das ganz viel wasser und
dann wird das eben trocken und das
brauchen wir gar nicht damit wir das
fleisch klein bekommen werde ich das
erstmal mit dem messer mit den klein
schneiden und dann brauchen wir so ein
wiegemesser wenn die ein größeres hat es
noch besser denn dann könnt ihr das so
richtig zu hackfleisch verarbeiten wie
gesagt es ist nur wichtig dass ihr das
per hand
denn diese arbeit kann keine maschine
ersetzen
[Musik]
ich bin jetzt gerade weil mit dem
wiegemesser das alles zu hackfleisch zu
verarbeiten und das ist auch ganz
wichtig also wie gesagt wenn ihr schon
vorbereitet das hackfleisch kauft dann
ist es kein adana ihr müsst es wirklich
selber machen das kann wie gesagt keine
maschine ersetzen und es ist auch ein
bisschen anstrengend ihr werdet ein
bisschen schwitzen aber das lohnt sich
also die welt am ende ein richtig
schönes zartes aber nach abhaben und
muckis das rindfleisch ist fertig das
hat ungefähr 15 minuten gedauert ich
habe inzwischen sind übrigens die gattin
zugemacht weil es hier sehr heiß war und
sehr viel sonne rein geschehen ist und
jetzt gebe ich das hat vielleicht einmal
in meine separate schüssel und als
nächstes nehmen wir uns unser
lammfleisch vor
[Musik]
das lammfleisch ist jetzt auch fertig
gehabt das war ein bisschen schwieriger
durch das ganze feld natürlich und da
das ganze dann auch dadurch ein bisschen
zäh ist also dauert auch automatisch
länger aber wenn ihr die schritte
erledigt habt dann ist die fleißarbeit
beendet und wir gehen rüber zu unserer
roten paprika die wir jetzt auch noch
ganz fein gehackt und mit dazu gegeben
[Musik]
die sehr fein gehackte paprika geben wir
jetzt mit zu unserem fleisch genauso wie
salz und paprika flocken und mehr
braucht ihr gar nicht das ist alles an
gewürzen alles andere ist unnötig und
gehört hier einfach nicht rein
und nachdem wir dass dazu gegeben haben
wir das noch mal zehn minuten richtig
ordentlich verknetet
[Musik]
ich habe das ganze jetzt zehn minuten
lang geknetet und das solltet ihr auch
unbedingt einhalten ihm merkt mit der
zeit dass sich da so ein bisschen die
konsistenz verändert was sie jetzt noch
wichtig ist wir geben da jetzt
frischhaltefolie drauf oder einen deckel
wenn ihr einen habt und dann geht das
ganze eine nacht lang in den kühlschrank
bitte unbedingt einhalten denn in der
nacht passiert freundes das ganze zieht
so müssen im fleisch eine ganze gewürzt
das heißt die ganzen es sind nicht viele
gewürze aber das zieht auch mal richtig
ein gibt noch mal richtig aroma und
geschmack ab und dann können wir das
ganze wochenende lief freu mich schon
also bis morgen so in ihrem eintrag
später haben in flyff die jetzt 24
stunden 110 im kühlschrank ich habe es
jetzt raus genommen noch einmal 20
minuten auf zimmertemperatur stehen
lassen dann kann man das einfach besser
form als wenn es jetzt ganz eisig kalt
ist und außerdem habe ich hier noch eine
schüssel mit wasser brauchen wir gleich
um uns die hände so ein bisschen zu
befeuchten und ganz wichtig woraufhin
dem ich das fleisch geben sind solche
adana spieße die sind speziell dafür
hergestellt sind noch gar nicht so teuer
die habe ich jetzt aus dem türkischen
supermarkt die sind nämlich breite
schlick spieße damit kommt er nicht weit
also dass das macht keinen sinn weil ihr
einfach das fleisch dran pressen ist und
dass auch relativ dünn ich zeige euch
jetzt wie das geht damit es eben auf dem
grill auch schön durch ist jetzt nehmen
wir uns alle handvoll fleisch dass es
immer passend für ein spielt das sind
ungefähr 180 gramm
hiermit aber nicht das ganze fleisch und
so dass jetzt sofort auch unser spiel
ist sondern ich nehme mir zu ein drittel
davon weg legt den rest zur seite und
dann fange ich an dass hier auf mein
spiel zu geben
[Musik]
ihr müsst darauf achten dass eure hände
immer wieder befeuchtet werden dann
könnte er das fleisch richtig gut
anpacken ohne dass ich wieder gleich
runter fällt
und jetzt kommt die typische form hier
bist du ein bisschen übung freilassen
weil das ja auch feuer grill kommt unten
genauso und in die mitte kommt das
fleisch und diese typische andernach
form bekommt ihr also euren zeigefinger
benutzt ihr nicht sondern alle anderen
finger und dann drückt ihr da so ein
bisschen rein und dann erhaltet ihr
diese typische form diagana so hat ganz
genau damit ich nämlich die spieße nicht
hier flach aufs bett liegen muss habe
ich mir so eine anhöhe gemacht ich habe
x3 oder spieße fertig gemacht das rezept
reicht übrigens für genau sechs spitze
180 gramm ungefähr
und ich mache jetzt nur drei weil ich
habe nur drei spießte da aber das macht
nichts dann mach ich dir jetzt und die
anderen drei mache ich nach herz und
jetzt gehen wir raus auf den balkon
bevor ich mich jetzt um die ander spitze
kümmern der grill ist übrigens schon an
zeige ich euch noch ganz schnell den
berühmten zwiebeln salat der bei madonna
nicht fehlen darf hierfür brauchen wir
nur ganz wenige zutaten und zwar ich
habe hier zwiebeln schon vorbereitet in
ganz dünne und feine scheiben
geschnitten
außerdem habe ich hier fein gehackten
tomaten fein gehackte petersilie ganz
wichtig zumal unser essig baum gehört
und etwas salz und das werden wir jetzt
alles miteinander vermischen und dann
mit den händen richtig schön kneten
[Musik]
so und jetzt gebe ich die drei spieße
einfach auf meinen tisch und dann werden
sie alle 40 bis 50 sekunden gewendet
wir brauchen außerdem für das rezept
lava stroh das hört ihr im türkischen
supermarkt ich zeige ich aber gerne auch
mal mein rezept bei gelegenheit in dem
moment wo die flammen auf steigen heißt
es unser fett tropft gerade auf die
kohle und das müssen wir verhindern und
deshalb nehmen wir uns sah dann packen
das einmal in unserer läufer sport nimmt
das fett einmal weg und dann geben wir
das zurück auf unseren grill
[Musik]
sobald eure spitze dann durch sind nimmt
ihr sie mit hilfe des lava sportes
einmal raus zeige ich euch jetzt also
einmal ganz weg drauf drücken und dann
abziehen vom spieß
neben dem zwiebel salat passen übrigens
am allerbesten tomaten und grüne paprika
zum dollar etwas
[Musik]
und genauso muss original adana sein
schmecken und aussehen ihr habt die
konsistenz gesehen ist es unglaublich
zart und wenn ihr alles beachteten die
ganzen tipps mitnehmen die ich euch
gegeben habt dann habt ihr hinterher ein
wunderbares lecker gegrilltes adana
knapp falls das ganze jetzt nach macht
schaut mal unten in die infobox da
stehen alle genauen mengenangaben drin
ansonsten freue ich mich über eure
leckeren fotos mit dem hashtag es geht
schon auf instagram freue mich wenn ihr
meinen kanal abonniert das video fleißig
teilt und dann sagen ich bis zum
nächsten mal auf die gis kitchen jeans
[Musik]